all right now to this story from the  world of sports for air quality from  Australia's bushfires delayed qualifying  matches at the Australian Open today it  comes one day after tennis pro Dalila  yaku Povich forfeited her match because  look at this guy she was coughing she  could not breathe a coughing fit that  bought her to the ground she later said  she had no prior breathing issues and  had never suffered from asthma a coupe  of a blasted tournament officials for  allowing the match to go on in the first  place saying it was quote not fair and  quote not healthy the state's chief  health officer says air levels in  Melbourne have reached quote the worst  in the world she said it felt like an  asthma attack you know he said no issues  before she's never had any issues and  there's a very big match coming up the  Australian Open starts next week  you